kind enough to have Reggie Miller and
Chris Webber here in the man cave and
the movie coming up tonight
uncle drew the world premiere Oh Chris
you used to live next to in the
neighborhood with reg and Malibu yeah I
was inaudible resident but Reggie
wouldn't let me come over his house or
not like that did you ever go to Reggie
somes I used to drive by and like look
over the gate beautiful who's got a
nicer house kevin garnett Kevin
Garnett's kgs house is not he's got long
money as so the number of black people
in Malibu is you son yeah I'll be back
there you cagey that's it and we're
holding it down Halle Berry made an
appearance one oh she did one one summer
she rented it down the Point Dume okay
just a dry bunch she wasn't there for
long home Noah considered drive-bys
residence okay do you remember the story
you were gonna tell oh my god do you
guys remember what we were talking about
that c-webb goes I got a great story and
I said hold off and then what was the
story does anyone know what we were
talking a John Howard story there's a
Duke story John Howard he told thanks
another good story okay so we were
talking about Chris's going back to
Michigan Jim Harbaugh reached out to him
how are you with teammates is that
important at all with the Fab five you
know relationship wise you know very
honestly Dan so much as me because other
people talking I haven't talked and I
think that could be good or bad
depending on how you look at it so I
have to take responsibility I guess for
whatever people think but I talked Juwan
like every frickin other day first of
all his ears are like Reggie so he can
hear me right now wherever he is he can
hear me so it's not like no but
and range one I talked too often I
haven't talked to Jalen in a while a
long time and that's about it but you
know you could not want to be a fly on
the wall on that could not be cool if
one person that'd still be cool with
four guys like you know you could not
like somebody still be cool with it then
that's you know yeah you know so this
whole thing of this whole thing of oh he
doesn't know he he can't come back
he's so heard about the time right he's
crushed and mentally he can't be with
all five of us like I don't you know it
is what it is I'm very happy that and
they're saying that who was setup who
was saying that you like I thought we
started seeing them on the screen right
here so I'm just assuming you know it's
like this I never wanted to make a
private beef personal for the world
right but because I've been trolled
like I think no human in the history of
sports has been trolled by you know
someone that you consider your friend
it's tough right but that doesn't mean
I'm not cool with everybody else like
you can't you can't take all power and
ownership and say he doesn't speak to me
or he's not cool dog getting back to the
University so it's never been like that
the guys are my boys and when your
brothers you're gonna get into it and
you'll get back together but what
happens though is we make more out of it
right and then we read into it and what
happens is we want an answer we want to
have a moment where you like Bob Knight
going back to Indiana I said to him
coach don't make this about the the
administration here make it about the
people and give them something now go
back for them yeah where is you know
it's difficult if you guys have a
reunion with the Fab five you can do it
like do it for the fans yeah and where
that varsity jacket and if you and Jalen
don't get along okay you can still
survive and and do something that's
really I think rewarding for those fans
as well like they should remember great
things about the Fab five I want them to
and it will happen but it has to be
it had to be natural and I had to be
really on on my time it had to be
something where you can have a
conversation and I think we're going to
have that conversation coming up because
I've just all these issues and but I
think it's something that you have to
have a conversation not people trying to
grass that for instance never the first
Final Four that that Michigan had or a
few years ago when they played in
Atlanta and everybody was saying what
Chris went up to a sweetie could well on
paper I still was banned from the school
so I go upstairs because you still can't
supposedly sit with the team and Doulos
knew you were allowed to be around the
team well it still was that it still was
that ban I think that was actually the
last year or something like that so
within that you can't go to the game so
let me take for credit for every time a
fire was put up a fire was made I didn't
come on say hey wait a minute it's not
like that that's not my personality and
that hurts a lot because the fans do
need to see that but I think that you
know we're gonna have some great
conversations and hopefully hopefully
the fans that go to Michigan they love
Michigan especially once as much as I do
we'll enjoy when we come back together
because there's also that's what we want
you guys sweat it as brothers a lot of
Tears together and I think that's what
especially old school and old heads like
me you know being older than you gettin
plain with Jalen I know how much he
loves you and I know how much you love
him but you're right part of the media's
job sometime is the kind of stir it up
because we want we we like I would love
to see you guys walk out yeah at
midcourt and wear the baggy shorts and
and Daria okay we're short our legs are
so strong
[Applause]
how about baggy pants you can wear your
warmups
but just to have you guys go out and go
out to midcourt in huddle up Dan there's
nothing nothing I would want more than
that and I think that I I think we're on
the right path for that but I think has
to be conversation I think it has to be
organically and organically and that's
the thing like very honestly a lot of
people were pushing it for money because
the doc was a lot of people's pushing it
for you know and my thing is you know
you have to be sincere address and then
move forward because all the other stuff
is always gonna be there and do it for
anything else if we start that way we're
gonna end up right back where we are and
so then you're right for the fans I want
to do it for myself for my family for
Hooper's so hopefully it's something
where I think we're working towards it
and you also look at the the impact of
five fat fat five had though now it I
don't know if you guys played with the
chip on your shoulder like it always
felt like it was you guys against the
rest of the world yes but why was it you
guys against the rest of the world or
did that feeling that you guys had Wow
so so I've been in this kind of really
reflective moment over the last six
seven years I've been writing a book
tour the doc and you have to go through
some tough things mentally to figure it
out and when you say that it's cuz of
our mentality when we came from you know
Juwan you know he was he was where he
was born and where he lived no human
should lived in Chicago you know he came
from when the worst areas ever you know
his grandmother support him passed away
the day he signed you know so as kids we
were seeing all these signs you know
what I mean crying with him on the phone
at high school because he lost his
grandma knowing where guys are coming
from knowing their different paths and
it was something that was so unique
something that was so sincere at the
moment that we just loved each other our
whole thing was you know at the time we
didn't have a TV in our dorm you know it
was not it wasn't that type of a party
so at that time I remember we were like
we're playing on TV for arm for our moms
bill walton called us thugs cuz we
shaved our heads bald and we were like
you know you go through like why would
you say that about me my mom's watching
then you go you know what screw you
oh dude you can't even play anyway hate
melded coach Fisher would get you know
about first of all forget race well
first of all with five black guys so at
race now let now forget race when I look
back at some of our antics doing the
game just as a you know forty-five year
old guy I cringe sometimes like what so
long with that and then other people
that are just like what the heck do you
guys do it so it made us come closer and
in our walk on Freddie Hunter the rookie
our freshman year
Freddie Hunter who was a walk-on was our
captain and we loved it he had a job at
the first half of the year and we rally
behind him it was just something that
coming from Detroit where we were from
coming from Chicago we were putting the
city on our back where did that scale
where did that scale come from from you
know we're running down you just expect
off the court either on the court that
was did you learn that scowl when you
get got to Michigan now maybe my father
is probably my father before he whipped
me or before he talked give him the
credit for that
let's probably well I got that look but
it was it was so much fun it was you
remember that time guys when you were
yourself the last time you were like a
kid you were stupid but you all right
you know you had a love in your head
loving your hair to want to take on the
world and help people it was the perfect
storm and we around great people great
coaches that really really helped her so
I I don't know where all of it came from
down but it was it was not fake it was
sincere I wanted to ask you guys if you
were recruiting LeBron James so let's
say like what would what would be your
pitch right now of trying to get LeBron
James to play let's say you read your
the Lakers mm-hm and c-webb you're gonna
be Cavaliers okay is that okay yeah I
like that I like
if I'm Magic Johnson I'm obviously would
call him maverick and his rich Paul in
and I would have all the championship
trophies miniature ones on the table and
I would recruit some of the guys James
Worthy Kobe and say we're all about
winning there's a culture here Kobe in
there Kobe has played against LeBron out
there my just a question that's all yes
okay I do want Kobe a table Kobayashi's
in Kobe ah she's in there I have my
Minister trophies okay I was like what
you want here tell me what players you
want and I will go get you got it
because you've got you've got to feed
his ego who do you want to play with and
I'm gonna do my damnedest to bring them
in and Kobe is gonna help me right Kobe
yeah here we go here here's the
Cavaliers Jim Chris Webber so we heard
you had a nice meeting you gonna go play
for Kobe Oh Kobe's your coach now right
I mean well you know if Maja's your
coach why they bring cobia Kobe is
always gonna be over you Wow I mean you
could score 40 points in 10 games in a
row you know what they're gonna say
you're the last person to do this since
[Laughter]
you can go there and it not be your team
if you don't make the playoffs just out
of how we are in the media time
including myself it's the worst thing
ever
if you guys lose to Denver who you could
lose to in the playoffs what makes you
think you could come here you've started
something a legacy don't fall for these
guys that just go and play with the
winners or their buddies you've done
something here no one else is done you
give thousands
is going away again in Cleveland and
that's what they said about you last
year LeBron and you get out you wanna go
play for Kobe wait can you wear number
can you even wear your number they
retire your number not 23 no 24 oh and
eight Andy so so yeah and you know what
we will not guarantee to retire your
number and we can't do that and if we do
we have to trade you that would be part
of my pitch if I'm magic your number is
going up game one okay oh and by the way
if I'm magic
here's that letter that Dan Gilbert
wrote about you they really like Ice
Cube would say by the way it was your
leather jacket that you had a story
about do you remember your your
letterman jacket oh I got the story I
think I said okay you know now I've lost
like the energy I was not that good but
I were talking about Grant Hill now how
I had this letterman jacket so my father
and told me that I had the jersey so
after we played Duke ain't championship
because I was gonna go there they beat
us first championship Laettner knows
guys grant takes off his jersey his
whole uniform shoes gives it to my
little brother and next to next to my
varsity jacket I have Grant Hill this
whole because I stole it from a grant
gave your brother his gear his whole
Duke uniform and they won the
championship against us and Laettner
gave his to you which I thought was
interesting
see web shows women
alright the movie tonight the premiere
it'll be red juicy web guy Regis Nate
Robinson
Nate can still play right did you see
him go off in the big three
he heard the game when it shot and he
stole somebody's Chucky Mass and tried
to start a shot hard like McCann yeah
should be back in the league you think
you can still play yes oh yeah at the
end of the benches on some of these
teams
yeah and they should be in the league
why aren't you in the whole thing thank
you I would love to be I don't know and
thank you when you don't have control
that assemble eyes that I'm have to you
know give up you know ain't thoughts are
of a while ago really yeah why Andy in
the Hall of Fame range I think politics
I think a lot of things that we've
talked about today and the Basketball
Hall of Fame it's on the NBA all right
it's it's everything you did
internationally it's what you did in
college you know so that's well just
like we just seen with Jim Harbaugh time
heals all wounds the invitations been on
the table for so many years for him to
come back and now he's accepted I think
people now are starting to settle in
this is a not only a great basketball
player but a great talent and good
person I hope that the fab fought the
Michigan situation is not why you're not
in the whole thing is that that's that
doesn't seem fair to you as a basketball
player right they change the culture of
calling I know we know their impact I'm
just curious why you're not the whole
thing and you know I actually thought
you were like for God and then I went
wait see Webb's not in the whole thing
yeah but you know what it has made
appreciation for because the first thing
you want to do human nature very
honestly is to look at people in the
Hall of Fame and compare yourselves to
them and through this whole exercise of
just you could being humble is
you know what it's an honor to be in
there and if you're not you know just
wait your turn but I'm lucky and I'm
blessed though let me say this that I
get to work with these guys because I
hear that you're a better man this the
locker room every day with jerks like
Reggie Stern but if you get into the
Hall of Fame you could be in there with
Bill Walton that old man that you would
don't go pretty good players there wait
that's your bill wolf have you had a
conversation with him since probably
probably not right I'm sure having it
it's probably been like cuz it was 25
years he even remember that he comes
stick his stick yeah I don't take it as
personal you know it's like a lot of
forgiveness a lot of water under the
bridge but I do know that that inspired
me to go in and play against some of the
best when you have him talking about it
you know I just wish I would have Google
in to go back the movie tonight the
premiere and it'll be released
nationally on Friday night it's uncle
drew by the way just do me a favor
tonight there's one favor that's it act
like you know the dance when you see
them you will reg but see Webb he's been
known you're good
we're back after this in the Dan Patrick
show for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]